Це відео 4-річної Аліси, дочки медика з Маріуполя, буквально стало віральним і поширюється в соцмережах
із закликом до міжнародної спільноти про допомогу з організацією діючих гуманітарних коридорів для евакуації
мешканців з міста, взятого в облогу російськими військами. Маленька Аліса вже понад 50 днів
знаходиться в одному з бункерів на заводі "Азовсталь".
За даними Маріупольської міськради, у підземних укриттях меткомбінату досі перебувають сотні цивільних:
переважно жінки з дітьми та літні люди. Українські військові просять світ вивезти людей і поранених
із металургійного комбінату у третю
державу - лік на години.
Це наше звернення до світу. Це може бути нашим останнім зверненням. У нас, можливо, залишилися лічені
дні або години. Ми звертаємся до світових лідерів допомогти нам. Ми звертаємось з проханням застосувати
до нас процедуру extraction та вивезти нас на територію третьої держави.
Раніше морпіх назвав те, що відбувається у Маріуполі, "пеклом на землі".
У мене мало часу, щоб описати всі жахіття, які я бачу тут щодня. На заводі в бункерах живуть жінки з дітьми,
немовлятами. У голоді та холоді.
Щодня під прицілом ворожої авіації.
Щодня помирають поранені, бо немає медикаментів, немає води, немає їжі. Я звертаюся до вас по допомогу.
Бо настав час, коли не єдиними молитвами.
Допоможіть врятувати їх!
Повідомляється, що російські військові розпочали штурм комбінату "Азовсталь". Відео, на яких видно, як у бункерах
заводу ховаються мирні жителі, міноборони Росії називає фейками і стверджує, що там перебувають
лише дві з половиною тисячі бійців батальйону "Азов". Українські військові, оточені російськими військами
в Маріуполі, вкотре відмовилися від пропозиції міноборони Росії скласти зброю і здатися в полон.
Залишки української армії та велика група мирного населення фактично оточені російськими військами.
Вони продовжують боротьбу. Але судячи з того, як поводиться російська армія в Маріуполі,
російські військові вирішили
за будь-яку ціну зрівняти місто із землею.
Ситуація у Маріуполі продовжує погіршуватися. Президент Зеленський оголосив,
що Москва стартувала другу активну фазу війни.
Вже найближчим часом вони хочуть буквально добити та знищити Донбас. Знищити все, що колись дало славу
цьому промисловому регіону. Також, як російські військові знищують Маріуполь, вони хочуть
стерти з землі й інші міста,
інші громади Донецької та Луганської областей.
Британська політологиня Аглая Снєткова переконана, що Москва зосередила всі свої найбоєздатніші частини
на Донбасі для завершального наступу на Україну.
Для Росії це свого роду "останній військовий шанс". Якщо вони програють битву за Донбас, то буде враження,
що вони програли війну. Тому очікується, що російські війська сфокусуються на цьому напрямку
і намагатимуться зробити все, що можна.
Тому, на думку Снєткової, захоплення Маріуполя - питання лише кількох днів.
Водночас Френк Ледвідж, відставний британський офіцер, який служив на Балканах, в Іраку та Афганістані,
не впевнений у швидкій перемозі РФ
у битві за Маріуполь та Донбас.
Я припускаю, що в найближчі кілька днів ми побачимо битву, яка дуже буде нагадувати битву під Сталінградом
із заводом "Червоний жовтень". Німцям знадобилося 3 місяці для того, щоб
- точніше, вони протрималися 3 місяці... Я не думаю, що захисники Маріуполя і "Азовсталі" зможуть протриматися
так само довго, але це буде
найжорстокіша битва для обох сторін.
Швидше за все битва за Донбас триватиме близько двох тижнів, кажуть експерти.
Адже Москва хоче встигнути
здобути "перемогу" до 9 травня.
Однак багато попередніх планів Кремля було зірвано. Тож, друга фаза, на думку експертів, це програма-мінімум
для російської армії після невдалого наступу на Київ.
Перша фаза війни Росії не вдалася. Вони зазнали поразки під Києвом. Вони не змогли взяти Київ.
Тоді було заявлено, що перший етап завершено. Великих втрат було завдано українським збройним силам.
Але те, що насправді планувалося, тобто зміна влади, ймовірно, шляхом швидкого просування
в урядовий квартал Києва, досягнуто не було. Натомість росіяни зазнали великих втрат.
Тепер із цього виносять уроки. Це означає, що наявні резерви та війська РФ нині концентруються
на дійсно досяжній меті, а саме на завоюванні Луганської та Донецької областей
у їхніх межах або, можливо, і за їхніми межами.
Ключова пандемічна проблема російських військ залишається, і вона вплине на битву.
Вона полягає у корупції, у поганій логістиці, у поганому плануванні, у поганих структурах командування
та у застарілій доктрині. Вони, можливо, зберуться з силами. Ми вже бачимо формування військ в Ізюмі,
на півночі. Вони спробують наступати звідти.
Разом з тим російські війська продовжують обстрілювати інші регіони України, навіть Львів.
Експерти вважають, що цим Москва хоче дати сигнал.
Росія продовжує завдавати ударів по цивільному населенню. Намагається дати зрозуміти,
що безпечних територій немає. Мовляв, ми дістанемося до вас і вб'ємо вас, де би ви не були.
Приміром, удар по Краматорську. Це сталося одразу після того, як українська влада
закликала місцевих евакуюватися. У відповідь росіяни обстріляли зону евакуації на вокзалі.
Це свого роду стратегічний удар. Його мета - підірвати моральний дух населення.
Але як завжди, вони досягли цим протилежного ефекту.
Віце-прем'єрка Ірина Верещук повідомила, що 20 квітня має працювати гуманітарний коридор з Маріуполя
до Запоріжжя для жінок із дітьми та літніх людей.
Гуманітарних коридорів в Україні не було вже кілька днів, а з Маріуполя людей не випускали ще з 11 квітня.